Would you recommend that all cancer patients take B-17? No. Or would their genetics indicate? No.
This protocol is not recommended to me by you, but I have recently begun to take
African Power B-17 in a protocol that works up to a high doses. I have a fun
dating tumors. I have fun dating tumors. Is there any information available that shows
that B-17 will be beneficial to reduce or healing these tumors for the wounds
they create? I don't know. It's gonna be really hard. You have to use duck.go or
something to search for resources on B-17 because that's Laya trail and Laya
trail is something that has been just shut down by Google. So I do have information on
that website, but I don't have anything specific on what you're talking about there.
So we'll have to use a multiple search engine to search for them.